it has been 1 352 days
since the 2016 presidential election
and hillary clinton is still complaining
about as she did not win
and more than that she is still peddling
a conspiracy
theory that she was cheated out of the
white house
by trump by roger stone by worst of all
russia by collusion here is
her cockamamie theory well i think it's
pretty clear
that stone threatened him uh he probably
threatened him privately but he also
threatened him publicly about what he
would say
if he uh had to go to prison and this is
a continuation
of the cover-up it's an ongoing uh
cover-up that uh trump
and stone are two of them major
participants in
to try to prevent us from knowing all of
the details
about what they actually did in 2016.
uh some of it was very public i mean
asking russia
in public uh to uh interfere in an
american election but some of it was
um clandestine behind the scenes sending
messages the kinds of things that
we know about and i think much more uh
so what he did
was to use the awesome power of
commutation as part of the pardon power
of the president
uh to basically shut up roger stone
uh so that roger stone would not uh
spill any more beans about what actually
happened and how much
donald trump actually knew roger stone
and donald trump must get so much
pleasure out of watching this woman
dissemble like this
because it was stone it was trump it was
putin it was boris it was natasha it was
everybody's fault but her own
and so she's now attacking trump for
using the pardon power
you know how many times trump has used
the pardon power the power of
commutation
36 times do you know how many times
hillary clinton's husband
used the pardon power and power of
communication 456 times
one of the most famous abusers of the
pardon power ever for political
reasons hillary says there was a
conspiracy
to hurt her keep her out of the white
house in fact we know there was a proven
conspiracy
to try to keep trump out of the white
house through the politicization of the
fbi and doj
the problem was that conspiracy didn't
work
lots of double standards going on here
between how
the mainstream apparatus the
establishment big tech
news media are treating the leftist
conspiracy theories
compared to the right ones we will
plunge the depths
of conspiracy i'm michael knowles this
is the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show not all
conspiracies
are made equal some are a little more
dangerous than others we'll get to that
in one second first i have to get
to the question that i asked you all
yesterday i said
what do you think is the best nickname
for that
naked portland protester who is being
referred to as naked athena
and best comment i saw out there is
meduza
i like the idea of sticking with greek
mythology here but i don't think that
that naked protester
is athena the goddess of wisdom
something tells me she is more like
medusa
didn't see the front of her face which
is good because then i might turn to
stone
and today's question i have for all of
you on this topic of conspiracies
on this topic of is getting kicked off
the internet
who is mr q
who is the cue have you heard of q q
is the most dastardly awful terrible
conspiracy theory in the whole wide
world it's so bad
that twitter is going to start banning
accounts
that talk about it talk about that thing
that i don't really know very much about
twitter tweets out yesterday is from
twitter safety
the committee for safety you've got to
watch out you're in danger
because you might read words that you
don't like we've been clear
that we will take a strong enforcement
action on behavior that has the
potential to lead to offline harm
in line with this approach this week we
are taking further action on so-called q
anon
activity across this service q anon i
don't know very much about q anon
we get some questions about it sometimes
but i i
haven't looked into it particularly
deeply but from what i gather from the
twitter
safety tweet this is a very dangerous
conspiracy theory
very dangerous conspiracy theory that is
percolating
on the right and so they've got to shut
down any account
that's in any way associated with it but
i notice
twitter safety doesn't care that much
about dangerous conspiracy theories
percolating on the left that lead to
offline harm for instance
there is a conspiracy theory out there
held on the left
by you know kind of kooky people on the
left that
black people are the real jews and the
jews are the fake jews you would have
seen this conspiracy theory just in the
last week
because nick cannon very famously
endorsed this theory louis farrakhan
who is a hate monger who's still on
twitter by the way
these people have promoted this idea
sometimes you see people on street
corners talking about it but you've seen
a lot of people
on twitter talking about it then
actually when nick cannon was forced to
make an apology
a lot of the responses to that tweet
said come on stand up you add the truth
tell the truth so
that's also a conspiracy theory by the
way that has
led to violence in the real world we
know for a fact that's led to outside
harm twitter doesn't care about that one
here's another conspiracy theory on the
left racist cops are
systematically slaughtering black men
across the country innocent black men
it's not happening
we went through the numbers of unarmed
black men last year who were killed by
police officers
and by the way don't forget unarmed does
not mean not dangerous does not mean
that the killing was not justified
but the number is not 90 000 not 900
not 90 it's 9.
nine so that is a ridiculous conspiracy
theory and now
cops are being killed because of that
conspiracy theory all around the country
twitter encouraging that pushing it on
using the hashtag black lives matter
which is used to organize
those kind of violent riots by
self-avowed
trained marxists and then the third
conspiracy theory that was allowed to
percolate and still is
that donald trump the man we've known
for 40 years is actually a manchurian
candidate a stooge
for russia that's the most ridiculous
conspiracy theory of all
that one was pushed by the doj the fbi
big tech the mainstream media every
mainstream publication
it's still being pushed even though we
now know for a fact it didn't happen
because we had a two and a half year
multi-multi-million dollar
investigation from bob mueller came up
with zilch what about those can i think
those conspiracy theories
in particular the russia one have had a
far greater outsized
impact on the real world than some
tweets about q don't you think i think
so
and yet twitter everybody's only
targeting
those right-wing conspiracies this idea
of the
conspiracy theory they always just throw
it on the right the left has
many crazy conspiracy theories they have
many crazy theories in general they
think men can be women and they think
babies aren't babies
but they're not treated in the same way
and even that
category that idea of going after the
conspiracy theory
is a way to push
cockamamie left-wing theories and
suppress
right-wing theories we will turn to some
strange shenanigans speaking of
conspiracies that do have a lot of
evidence
over in nashville you've heard me talk
yesterday i mentioned
that a friend of mine in los angeles
went in to take a coronavirus test
the line was like two hours long so she
signed in but she didn't take the test
she leaves and then she gets a call a
day or two later
that said that she tested positive but
she obviously didn't test positive
because she didn't take the test now
we've gotten people writing into this
show who have said that multiple times
i've gotten probably three letters about
that already we know
that texas had to adjust some numbers
about 3 000 numbers or more
of their positive coronavirus cases
because the reporting was bad
because they were not actually confirmed
cases and now there's a guy in nashville
who went on the local news channel to
talk about the same
damn thing happened to him
i'm 100 sure that's what she said
because she's looking right at it and
she's
specifically told me i'm right here in
the system that you're showing positive
she says well i'm still seeing that
you're positive
courtesy caller checking your symptoms i
don't know what's going on
but it's wrong and then i'm just another
number when i'm not
i like his take he said i don't know
what's going on but it's wrong
it's obviously wrong because the guy
doesn't have coronavirus
when we think about this does it have to
be some elaborate conspiracy theory with
the illuminati and the freemasons
and you know no not necessarily
i mean obviously the reason that
conspiracy theories take hold
is that sometimes there are conspiracies
you know we've been talking about
jeffrey epstein recently talk about
a conspiracy theorem that's one that was
proven true there actually was
an international elite pedophile ring
that had its own
private island and jeffrey epstein was
the guy running it then jeffrey epstein
you know didn't make it out of jail and
so they've got the other gal elaine
maxwell but it implicated very
high-level people
it implicated bill clinton who flew on
the lolita express multiple times it
implicated prince andrew
implicated lots of people people are
trying to say it implicated trump
because trump
uh knew epstein in palm beach and palm
beach was a member or
epstein was a member of mar-a-lago so i
guess i mean even that doesn't look
great
but he didn't fly on the jet quite like
bill clinton did anyway it involved
a lot of upper-level people and that's
how conspiracy theories take hold
i'm not interested in that what i'm
interested in
is the gaslighting it's a slight
distinction
the conspiracy theory has this whole
elaborate system what the gaslighting is
is when the left just lies to you when
they tell you not to believe your own
lion eyes and that is what they're doing
right now particularly on coronavirus
andrew cuomo
who handled this coronavirus worse than
any governor in the country
and whose policies are responsible for
thousands of senior citizen deaths
andrew cuomo had the audacity to sit in
front of a news conference
and say that now new york not only is
handling this
virus better than anybody but that
people are fleeing other states
to come to new york the problem is
you have it increasing now in
40 states across the nation
how do you keep the virus in 40 states
coming from new york we now have people
coming to new york
fleeing the other states because it's
the quote unquote safe state
so we have people coming here just for
the purpose of
fleeing the virus in their state
i think i have a little insight into
what andy cuomo is doing here because i
happen to be a new yorker of italian
abstra
extraction just like just like andy
cuomo
there's a little bit of an exaggeration
factor that goes on here when new
yorkers are bsing
so what he's trying to say is i'm not
responsible for thousands of people's
debts i know that new york
handled this worse than anybody but
please don't blame me that's what he's
trying to say
so what he he has to push a little too
far so he says oh yeah new york's doing
great yeah new york's doing better than
anybody actually actually you want to
know what i hear from people
people tell me all the time they say
they're coming to new york oh yeah they
can't they want to leave all their safe
states and come where the virus is
because of how good we're doing oh yeah
it's the it's like the whole thing of
like
this is the best pizza ever in the
history of the world you can you think
you think that there has ever been a
pizza better than the pizza in my pizza
shop never
never ever not in naples not anywhere
not at any time
historians will write about this pizza
it's that kind of exaggeration factor
trump does it a little bit himself
but he's not doing it on important
matters of policy
trump will will do that kind of thing
when he's talking about crowd sizes
things that are kind of tangential to a
story andy cuomo is doing that when
we're talking about the actual
epidemic and it
obviously erodes trust in institutions
and it erodes trust in politicians
and it's the reason that a lot of
cockamamie theories take hold
we will get to some more deception
and gaslighting in new york but first
i've got to thank our friends over at
rock auto you know it can be very
frustrating
when you just need to get a simple thing
fixed on your car
and it can take hours or days or lots of
headaches or too much money
rockauto.com is a family business
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years
go to rockauto.com to shop for auto and
body parts
from hundreds of manufacturers best
thing here this is my favorite part
prices at rockauto.com are always
reliably low
and they are the same for professionals
and do-it-yourselfers so
sometimes you go into the brick and
mortar store and then you need a part
and they don't have the part they order
it online probably from rockauto.com
then it comes in they charge you twice
as much you don't need that for me
someone like me i don't know very much
about cars
but my cars do break sometimes the
rockauto.com catalog
is so easy to navigate that even i can
do it
extraordinarily impressive they have a
great selection head on over to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for your car
or truck write knowles know wlas in
their how did you hear about us box
so that they know we sent you more
deception in new york a little bit i
guess
this is some good news this is a little
bit of a silver lining
of our statue toppling culture right now
but i think it's to serve dishonest ends
since the beginning of the statue
toppling we've said okay if you're going
to tear down
george washington because he was a bad
guy you're going to tear down thomas
jefferson because he was a bad guy
how come nobody's tearing down margaret
sanger margaret sanger
was the founder of planned parenthood
the eugenicist
who said very terrible things about on
issues of race
for one but also just on
issues of human development she talked
about how we need to get rid of people
who are
you know mentally handicapped or people
who have
disabilities because they're undesirable
so
planned parenthood has this problem
because
margaret hanger founded them they still
live out her philosophy
and her name is on a number of buildings
so the new york planned parenthood
has disavowed margaret sanger over
genetics here's the new york times
story on this ms sanger a feminist icon
and reproductive rights pioneer
supported a discredited belief
in improving the human race through
selective breeding the problem
is that planned parenthood may have torn
down the statue
but they still support that theory
in fact that's the only thing they
support
that's the whole point of planned
parenthood improving the race
the human race through selective
breeding either improving the human race
by liberating women from the shackles
and bondage of motherhood that's one way
that they
think they're improving the human race
and the other way they're they think
they're improving the human race
is by killing undesirable babies
undesirable that's the same word that
margaret sanger used right maybe these
babies are undesirable because
the mothers one because they they might
have some birth defects
or because the mothers don't like the
fathers or just because they don't want
them
because the babies are unwanted
selective breeding that's the phrase
that is you know
absolutely unthinkable today and that's
why the new york times thinks they tore
down the statue
selective breeding just means planned
parenthood
planned parenthood means selective
breeding planned
means selective it's not all happening
at once it's not totally arbitrary you
are
choosing it breeding
is parenthood it's a kind of inhuman way
to talk about parenthood but that's the
it is exactly what it means they haven't
changed a damn
thing they're not tearing down the
statue because they want to change
something
that the radicals on the streets of
america are tearing down george
washington
because they want to fundamentally
change america and get rid of george
washington's ideas
and by taking down our admiration of
george washington changed the way we
think about ourselves and how the
country should be run
the people taking down margaret sanger's
name at the planned parenthood in new
york
want to preserve exactly her mission
they don't want to change anything
they just want to deceive you
that's it you know margaret sanger at
least was honest about what she thought
and what she wanted to do
here planned parenthood has the same
eugenics policy
they just they just are dishonest about
it that probably won't be taught in
schools
something tells me people people are
taught especially i
went to school in new york right went to
k through 12 in new york
margaret sanger's taught us this
wonderful pioneer feminist icon all the
same stuff
the new york times was using to describe
her
that will probably not be taught in
schools though there will be a lot
more radicalism taught in schools if joe
biden gets elected president because joe
biden
this guy appears on camera what once
every few days
from the comfort of his living room it
could easily be edited it could easily
be
be massaged so he doesn't put his foot
in his mouth
and he still manages to do it most
recently by saying that he wants
as part of his campaign platform he
wants the islamic faith
to be taught in schools look one of the
things i think is important i wish
i wish we taught more in our schools
about the islamic faith i wish we talked
about
all the great confessional face it's one
of the great confessional face
and what people don't realize is one of
my avocation is theology
don't realize is that we we all come
from the same root here
in terms of our fundamental basic
beliefs and uh
i just want to thank you for uh for
giving me the opportunity for being
engaged for committing
uh to action this november you're doing
what's been
that's uh that's never been done before
you're registered and turning out
one million muslim voters this november
there we go i was wondering where did
joe biden get this recent
love of islam from where did since since
when
is joe biden trying to set up madrassas
all over the country oh it's because
he's pandering for votes
as he always is so he says we want to
turn out a million muslim voters and you
got to vote for me and i want the
islamic faith taught in schools
consider the absurdity that we have come
to
it is unconstitutional to teach the
bible in schools
which means it's unconstitutional to
teach christianity in schools
can't teach christianity without
reference to the bible it's not possible
so as of the mid 20th century when the
supreme court decided to legislate from
the bench
and and say that it's unconstitutional
to teach the bible in schools
and yet it's now being encouraged to
teach islam in schools and this is the
way it works i remember even when i was
in
high school and middle school long long
ago
not that long ago in new york
we were taught much more about islam
than we were about christianity we were
taught much more about islamic history
than we were about
christian history we were taught much
more about the middle east than we were
taught about european history
the european history course was an
elective you had to you had to choose to
take that
but the world history course which
focused heavily on islam
was required for two years
this is already happening it's not it's
not going to be joe biden who you know
his joe biden's pandering for votes
that that is going to get this across
the finish line there is a major double
standard here some people have said well
michael they're just teaching about the
faith
sure right but they're not teaching
about the christian faith because you
can't teach
about a faith without some reference to
its source texts
right so you can say no bible but yeah
we got to read the hadiths
i don't think so there's this double
standard it's a double standard being
leveled
on on how we teach
faith and religion how we respond to our
historical figures how we build up
statues and monuments
even on how we deal with conspiracy
theories there's a double standard
anything the right does is bad anything
the left does is good anything the left
wants
is good and the effect on our schools
isn't just on the curriculum it's on the
teachers themselves
even a teacher who all this teacher said
was to observe that donald trump is our
president
and that teacher got fired we will get
to that story in just one second first
though
i've got to thank our friends over at
ancestry
i love learning about my family history
and where my family came from
as history is being erased all around us
it's
very edifying to take a little bit of
control and hold over your own history
learn the story yourself an ancestry dna
test tells you where your ancestors are
from
and ancestry's billions of records and
millions of family trees let you
discover
their personal stories you could find a
famous relative
you can maybe find a photo of your great
grandma as a little girl whatever you
find
it is sure to change the way you look at
your family history and therefore
the way you look at yourself i love
ancestry i've been using ancestry since
before
the daily wire even existed i think
genealogy is a terrific hobby
i love doing it especially for people
who are a little more history inclined
you know you just even for people who
aren't by the way it will
get you excited about history because
it's about your own family history
uh right now start exploring your family
history head over to my url
ancestry.com knowles to get your
ancestry
dna kit and start your free trial that
is ancestry.com
slash knowles k-n-w-l-e-s
a teacher has been fired at the walled
lake
school district just 30 miles northwest
of detroit
not for saying anything crazy
and outrageous and offensive or
conspiractorial
not for even offering his political
preference
though as you know many teachers talk
about their political preferences all
the time
he simply observed the fact that donald
trump is the president
here's the quote he tweeted out i'm done
being silent
donald trump is our president don't at
me
you know don't don't come at me don't
attack me for that
if you now say donald trump is the
president
at this high school outside of detroit
you could be fired
here's what one parent said about it it
kind of gives up the whole game kind of
shows us the lesson of how to deal with
this this parent who was quoted
by the washington free beacon said quote
justin coached my son his entire high
school career
and also was his ap history teacher and
student leadership teacher for two years
i know justin very well if there's one
thing that i would commend justin for is
he always tried to stay
apolitical he always tried to stay right
down the middle
avoid political conversations and let
the students make their own call based
on their own
life experiences
well that's why that's why that's what
we don't get that's what people on the
right just
cannot understand if you stand in the
middle
if you are quiet about your views if you
don't attack people for their political
views
you think that you're being coy if you
don't voice your opinion on trump around
the water cooler
you think you're being coy you think
you're playing it straight you're not
you are outing yourself as a
conservative because
that that old idea of keep your mouth
shut about politics
is not the way the left is operating
right now this is why
in hollywood the left is always making
these professions of faith to leftism
i think a lot of the time it's not even
because they want to it's because
there's so much pressure to
if you are not constantly professing
your
great adherence to leftism then you are
assumed to be
a conservative that actually speaking of
hollywood that's how you can always tell
the hollywood conservatives
the guy who's quiet on set about
politics the guy who's quiet backstage
about politics
that's the conservative 99 times out of
a hundred
that i could i could guarantee i would
put a lot of money down
and say the guy who's quiet and doesn't
engage in those political conversations
in hollywood
that guy voted for trump we can't
remain in this defensive position the
left is not going to allow us to remain
in this defensive position
they're not going to allow us to play by
the old rules
the left was happy to play by these
rules of neutrality
and free speech when they were a
political minority that's why the left
pushed the free speech movement
in the 1960s and 70s why did they do
that
is it because they loved free speech no
it's because their anti-american
subversion
was being silenced rightly so in many
cases
and so they pretended to care about this
principle of free speech
and then the moment that they became the
dominant cultural force
they quashed free speech for everybody
else we can't just go right back to that
neutral playing ground it doesn't exist
and frankly
it probably never existed if this
teacher in outside of detroit
if he had taught the lies of the 1619
project
if he had taught the demonstrated lie
that the new york times has peddled
to the tune of three million dollars and
won a pulitzer 4 that america was
founded
explicitly to protect slavery that
teacher probably would have gotten a
promotion
but because he told a simple and obvious
truth
he lost his job
that that is a conspiracy you know
that's not a it's not a conspiracy
theory we can see it before our own eyes
i think some people are drawn
like moths to a flame to these kind of
crazy
intricate conspiracy theories because
they're kind of fun to engage in they're
signs of an active mind right you
put it's like playing a puzzle right you
put all these pieces together
the real conspiracies are right right in
front of our eyes
the fbi and the doj abuse their power to
try to subvert the
the trump campaign and the 2016 election
we know that that's a big conspiracy
theory
conservatives in public education
or in academia are discriminated against
we know that it's
it's a conspiracy theorem we see it
right before our eyes it's a little less
saucy
than some of the more intricate stuff
but that's where the battle is really
being waged
here's another conspiracy theory that
the left or
it's a conspiracy theory that the left
is pushing that there is this epidemic
of racist cops
gutting down unarmed innocent black men
around the country maxine waters
one of the craziest and most dangerous
members of congress maxine waters
who called for leftist mobs to attack
conservatives
in public just a few years ago
maxine waters pulled over her car
recently because she saw a traffic stop
and she got out of her car in the middle
of the road and started yelling at the
cops because the cops had pulled over
a black man in a car you blow it over
i stopped to see what they were doing
okay they say
i'm in the wrong place that's okay
as long as i watch this gotta do what
they gotta do make sure
all right so that video being filmed by
the people who were pulled over
and you see these cops they're on the
side
and they threatened maxine waters they
said you can't just leave your car in
the middle of the road
and get out and start yelling at us we
we might give you a ticket
and then she flexed her political power
and they just let her off with a warning
how outrageously disrespectful for the
civil authority
to come out and start screaming at the
law enforcement officers without any
evidence that they're doing
anything wrong just based on a fiction
that there is this epidemic of racist
cops killing black men around the
country
maxine waters explained to tmz what she
was thinking she said
my first thought was not again
not one more killing and i'm reflecting
on all of the killings of young black
men in particular
but of course black women too at the
hands of the police and at the hands of
these white supremacists
and i'm thinking about the way that the
president conducts himself
in a way he's dog whistling and i think
that they're feeling
that they can get away with this kind of
treatment and i'm just so sorry about
the loss of another life
nothing that woman said is true
the only thing that's true is that she
felt it but nothing that she's saying
she felt is true
it's it is a cra that the conspiracy
theory she's peddling there
is a lot crazier than anything about mr
q okay
and twitter is not going to take that
down they're not going to take down
maxine waters
but it's so colomnious it's so
outrageous to say that our our cops are
all killers
very very few single digits we're
talking about
officer involved killings of unarmed
black men and when you go through those
cases
very often those killings were justified
because you don't need to be holding a
gun
to pose a serious threat to a cop
are they gonna they're gonna take down
maxine waters i don't think so
meanwhile while we talk about the blm
movement
or i suppose while we don't talk about
the blm movement
blm racks up another body count they
killed another person
in a major fire that was lit during the
first riots
in minneapolis we will get to that in
one second and then we will get to the
threat the implicit threat
from the left at the bottom of all of
this first though
gotta thank you be sure to hit that bell
and check out
the exclusive content posted on the
michael knowles show youtube channel
we've got we've got one up there right
now which is the best of the worst
tick-tock videos we also have a
backstage coming up this friday 7 p.m
eastern
4 p.m pacific so be sure to check that
out and then get ben's book do i have a
copy of it no because i was reading it
yesterday
ben has a new book out it's called how
to destroy america
in three easy steps he did a live
signing about it yesterday that i was
hosting
you can pick it up at amazon or barnes
noble right now check it out and also
get a daily wire reader's pass
one buck for the first month and then
three bucks a month
after that you get access to our mobile
app articles ad free
access to exclusive editorials head on
over to dailywire.com we'll be right
back with a lot more
blm racked up another dead body
of people killed by the blm riots
the star tribune in minneapolis reported
that they found a charred
body of an unidentified man within the
wreckage of a
minneapolis pawn shop on monday this was
following the torching of that
establishment
at the end of may the man who was found
dead is chuck horton junior 43 year old
black male
oh i'm sorry that's another death sorry
there were two deaths the first one was
in the pawn shop
killed by blm rioters the second one is
chuck horton jr
43 year old black male who lay on the
sidewalk in front of the cadillac pawn
shop
with a gunshot wound to his torso he was
not breathing
a crowd of noisy protest protesters
gathered around
but they didn't help him they just put
him on video with their phones
and speculated about what took place all
those wonderful peaceful protesters
watched a man who had been killed by the
riots
bleeding out dying on the sidewalk
actually it was a cop
who knelt down by the man and performed
cpr while a second cop
waved off the protesters who were not
only doing nothing they were streaming
the death of a man on on the internet
but the cops are the bad guys and the
peaceful riders are the good guys
that's that's a conspiracy theory
where's that one does that one get
kicked off twitter i don't think so
then the implicit threat people didn't
realize this was a threat but it's a
threat this was in the new york times
it's written by mimi swartz
stay safe justice ginsburg this summer
has been hard enough
first line the only word to describe
life here right now is this
hell it talks about the pandemic and the
riots and all the craziness
hell yeah life has been a little tough
for a lot of people
for the last few months because the left
shut down our country and our economy
for no reason
on the basis of no scientific mandate to
to indefinitely lock down the country
then they torched the whole country and
burned it to the ground and then
where they had positions of political
power told the cops not to stop the
torching of the country
and the killing of people so it's yeah
it's been pretty bad
and then you get down one two three four
five six seven
eight nine ten eleven paragraphs before
you get to the point of this
op-ed she writes quote
of course one of the few people standing
between us and chaos
is justice ginsburg the anti-trump the
benevolent if steely matriarch
to stop all this craziness from going on
further
you see that one of the few people
standing between us and chaos is
ginsburg is that a description or is
that a prescription
is that a warning or is that a threat
the idea being if justice ginsburg
dies if there's a vacancy on the court
the country will descend
into madness because that will be the
straw that broke the capitals back and
we'll have
i would say outright conflict we already
have that in the streets but we'd have
more conflict
that's what the left is telling us
they're saying
don't push it don't defend the cops
don't defend your statues
don't defend your lives or property like
the mccloskeys in st louis
or we will arrest you or we'll send mobs
to go get you the new york times
almost sent a mob to tucker carlson's
house just the other day he actually
preempted them on it and stopped them
from doing it
maxine waters sent mobs to go after
conservatives in public
it's a threat they are
they're when they take down the
conspiracy theories from the internet
they say well this might cause harm to
people so we have to silence
anybody to the right of hillary clinton
you people are calling for mobs against
conservatives
that is calling for they don't care at
all about
what violence might happen online they
only care
if there's violence or if there's speech
even
that will undermine their position
that is the threat well meanwhile
hopefully thankfully
some people are finally pushing back the
department of homeland security
is finally going out as the madness in
portland and the pacific northwest
continues to rage i mean looking like
scenes from a third world country
finally the department of homeland
security is picking up the slack where
the local law enforcement
and the local civil authority is not
they are sending in people to arrest
the anarchists the dhs secretary
came on to describe this
on a martha mccallum show just the other
night and he's being lambasted for it
they are saying the left is saying that
this guy has absolutely no right to do
what he's doing
anytime that you attack a federal
facility such as a courthouse there in
portland
that is a federal crime attacking
federal police
officers law enforcement officers which
they have done for 52 nights in a row
is a federal crime and so the department
because we don't have that local support
that local law enforcement support
we are having to go out and proactively
arrest individuals and
and we need to do that because we need
to hold them accountable this idea that
they can attack federal property and law
enforcement officers and go to the other
side of the street and say you can't
touch me
is ridiculous we don't do that in any
other type of law enforcement
we pursue a criminal we investigate we
pull them over if you have probable
cause
we arrest them we charge them and we
prosecute them and you need to hold
individuals accountable and we don't do
that i think we get what we see in
portland today
did he say anything objectionable no of
course not and yet this was a top trend
on twitter yesterday because the left
was
saying that this was like minority
report he was going to go out and arrest
people before they committed crimes
which reminds me that the left
apparently doesn't know the meaning of
the word proactive
pro he says proactively arresting people
the feds are proactively arresting
people
not because they haven't committed
crimes yet but because the local
law enforcement will not arrest them
they're not permitted to arrest them
so rather than having local law
enforcement arrest these people and then
if it's a federal crime
the feds come in the feds are just going
straight in and doing that
it's not it's not preemptively arresting
them before they commit a crime it's
proactively arresting them and of course
that needs to happen
we do not want our city streets in
america to look like
some tin pot dictatorship which is what
they do
right now how crazy is that
that the left which pretends to care
about
violence which is trying to to suppress
conservatives on twitter
they're using this little excuse of the
cue story
to go after what i suspect will be many
many more people who are to the right of
hillary clinton they're they're
doing all of that in the name of
stopping violence and yet the minute
that a cop actually goes out and tries
to stop
the riots that are going on in the
street that are killing people
they cry foul they say you're absolutely
not allowed to do this
keith ellison attorney general in in
minnesota
keith ellison former vice chairman of
the
democratic national committee keith
ellison former congressman
just came out while discussing how law
enforcement is going to move into the
future
and said that rapists should not be
arrested
for their crimes we should not put
resources into getting cops to arrest
rapists
after they do what they do if you're a
woman
who's been a victim of a sexual assault
and the assailant is ran away
wouldn't you rather talk to somebody who
is trained
in helping you deal with
what you're dealing with as opposed to
somebody whose main training
is that they know how to use a firearm
right the ellison defenders the leftists
who are defending this guy are trying to
say now
that he's not talking about stopping
cops from arresting rapists
he's just saying in addition to all of
that we're going to have
some trained therapists or social
workers to come
and help the victim that's not what he
said he said wouldn't you
rather a therapist or social worker
comes up and
treats you as opposed to
not in addition to as opposed to a cop
going out and getting the rapist
they want the cities to burn they want
rapists to run free
they want any number of dangerous
theories
to percolate all around the country
they want you to not be civil with
people on the other side of the aisle
they want leftists not to be civil with
conservatives that's what hillary
clinton said
they want leftists to mob conservatives
in public and at their home where their
children sleep that's what maxine waters
said
they want all that sort of stuff all in
the name of peace
and stopping the violence and what is
the what does the right do
we try to play by some neutral standard
we think it's going to be applied
fairly we don't want to play their game
or engage in the way that they're doing
it
when you are in battle real battle or or
political battle
your opponent gets a say and if you are
not
fighting the real facts on the ground if
you're not dealing with the realities of
that battle
if you're fighting some imaginary battle
that you wish you were fighting
you're gonna lose if if
your opponent is aggressing on you and
you're living in a fantasy world where
everything is neutral
you are going to lose we
need to engage on the terms that the
left is foisting on us
i'll give you a great example of this
great example of this yesterday
a reporter was said to have possibly
referred to our beloved press secretary
kaylee mcinanny
who makes the national heart go
pitter-patter as a
lying b-i-t-c-h
now you could hear it on the audio
we all thought it happened for a moment
and this became a big story on twitter
take a listen and see what you hear but
i encourage you to read the op-ed
yes on the china vaccine research yeah
you've done two questions which is more
than some of your colleagues
yes thank you kelly okay okay did you
hear that at the end
okay you're a lying witch
something like that is that that's
that's what i heard the first time and
this kind of went around the internet
and some
conservative publications were pushing
this and conservative blue checkmarks
were pushing this but then
someone pointed out that it's
actually if you slow it down that's not
what she said
she said okay you don't want to engage
now initially
i thought this was a ridiculous excuse
so we slowed it down
take a listen of your colleagues
[Applause]
as much as it pains me i tried to listen
i tried to make sure that i was
not giving this woman too much credit
kimberly halckett at al jazeera
i think that's true i actually think
when you slow it down she did say okay
you don't want to engage
it sounded like you're lying you know
what in person
and surely the press thinks that about
kayleigh mcnaney but
in all fairness i don't think that's
what she said
here's the double standard when it
turned out that that's not what she said
then all the people who were spreading
this or at least a great great number of
them
took it down conservatives deleted the
tweets jack pasobic eddie zipper
the conservative publications that were
pushing this around they took it down
and
frankly they didn't even assert many of
them at first
that that is what the reporters said
they just raised the question is this
what the reporter said
and still they took it down i only
noticed this because
when i saw it happen i tweeted out a
joke about uh i was quoting this old
political philosophy book about how no
one should ever use a
course word at kaylee mcinanny and so i
but i saw the tweet was deleted and i
said okay that's good
conservatives are being fair about this
the left would never be fair would the
left ever
take down their tweets would they left
ever back off that lie
that they said about a conservative no
of course not and in fact we know that
they don't
a perfectly exemplary lie
donald trump called white supremacists
and neo-nazis very fine people at
charlottesville
that has become part of the leftist
gospel
joe biden launched his campaign on that
lie
that was the first part of the first
campaign ad to launch his campaign
and it's not true you can look one
paragraph down
trump explicitly says in charlottesville
i'm not talking about neo-nazis and
white supremacists they should be
condemned totally
and yet that lie moves on now i like
that conservatives tell the truth i
think we should continue to tell the
truth
but we should not accept any leftist
premise
that there is some sort of moral
equivalence here we should tell the
truth we should
we should not push fake news we should
not push conspiracy theories that are
not true
we should tell the truth but we should
stick by our side because these are not
fair games there is no moral equivalence
here
between trump and biden between right
and left between republican and democrat
they are not the same they are not
playing by the same rules they are not
pushing for the same goods
the left wants to destroy this country
and they're doing it right now
with torches while pulling down statues
well knocking down buildings
the right is trying to build up that
country again and we should not pretend
that the stakes are any lower than that
george will
considered one of the great conservative
columnists he's been a conservative for
a very long time
george will has come out and
endorsed joe biden
who do you plan to vote for in november
bye oh yes have you voted have you voted
for a democrat before
never first time you've ever voted for a
democrat for president
that's right although when i first came
to washington in 1970
to work on the senate staff my first
political hero as it were was a senator
a democratic senator with scoop jackson
of washington
uh i was working on the senate staff for
a republican
gordon elliot of colorado as i said
earlier my
best friend was senator from new york
pat monahan
so i've nothing against democrat but
i've never had the occasion to vote for
one this year i will
this year he how will this conservative
columnist
when the stakes are so high choose this
to be the year that he votes for the
democrat
who will empower all the people
destroying the country
few reasons one will in recent years has
become much more
libertarian not conservative he's moved
away from conservatism toward
libertarianism
which it brings you much closer over to
liberalism
or much more likely to side with
liberals will has always been a little
out of step with conservatism he's
rejected key conservative thinkers and
figures
will is an atheist will has been in
washington as he knows for a very long
time
which has this habit of making people a
little bit more liberal
will doesn't see the stakes here he does
even if he sees the stakes he doesn't
see
the double standard because what he sees
in trump is this crass
vulgar person who
tells the occasional exaggeration he'd
probably call it a lie
who doesn't have respect for our norms
and traditions
let's say that all of that is true let's
say all of that is true
will might be right about that what he's
wrong about
is that the democrats are doing all of
those things so much more so
the democrats much much much more vulgar
and grass
even joe biden himself has been vulgar
and crass at many times
biden has told many more lies than
donald trump deeper lies and the left
right now broadly which
biden would be empowering is telling
extraordinarily deep lies like america
was rotten and evil from the beginning
the cops are slaughtering innocent black
men and list goes on and on
that the 2016 election was illegitimate
right
the crazy conspiracies on the right
there are many more crazy conspiracies
on the left it's not that the critics of
the right are wrong
they're just not seeing how much more
egregious every terrible thing that you
could say about trump
or about the right is on the left
and applies to joe biden
especially this issue of the conspiracy
theories is really
really bugging me because they
increasingly you'll notice they hurl
this on the right
if you look at right-wing figures and
conservatives and thinkers and things
like that
increasingly they're adding the phrase
conspiracy theorists to their bios their
wikipedia pages even people who are as
mainstream
as they come why are they doing this
to distract from the fact that the left
is foisting some serious conspiracy
theories
on the country themselves i think of
this as the tin foil hat trick
three in a world they convinced the
country that trump was a manchurian
candidate a spy for russia
for goodness sakes then they convinced
us that we had to shut down the economy
indefinitely for this chinese virus
where other countries around the world
are not shutting down indefinitely
and i think indefinite means until the
november election now they're trying to
convince us
that we don't need any kind of
presidential campaign at all there can
be no debates had whether
literal presidential debates or broader
debates about who should win
no campaign rallies no nothing so that
biden has a better chance of getting
elected because the guy can't form
a coherent english sentence so they're
locking him in his basement
and convincing us we can't have a
campaign that's what the doctor ordered
so that they can get him into the white
house in 2020.
those conspiracy theories much more
egregious
much more dangerous have a far greater
public impact
than any that you see crop up on the
right
those are the ones that we should push
down those are the ones we have to fight
back against
and they're going to call us all sorts
of names when we fight back against them
doesn't matter
those are the stakes don't worry as much
about the criticisms that they're
leveling
at your side when all of those
criticisms apply
so much more to their own the stakes are
very
very high now is not the time to let
them
delude you that's our show get your
mailbag questions in for tomorrow in the
meantime i'm michael knowles
this is the michael knoll show see you
then
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies
executive producer jeremy bourie
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
technical producer
austin stevens assistant director pavel
wadowski
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico
audio mixer robin fenderson hair and
makeup
nika geneva production assistant ryan
love
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
20 20. hey everybody it's andrew clavin
host of the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the american republic is
collapsing the end of days is
approaching and the moon has turned to
blood
but on the andrew clavin show that's
where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me
andrew clayton